works right a company that prides itself
on offering what's trending when it
comes to pop culture collectibles like
the ones you see here is in town showing
off its latest offerings jessica piha
graffstein is the senior director at
funko you are at the las vegas licensing
expo where a lot of these collectibles
are on display how you doing jessica
hi kendall i am so glad to be back in
in-person events you know these past two
years it was really really hard but
licensing expo is back las vegas was
bumbling with all of our licensing
partners and we were able to showcase
some of our hottest products for 22.
yeah and what is hot right now these
days
you
a fan of something so whether that's
movies anime television sports or music
we believe that you have a fandom and
we're here to provide you with that
fandom to showcase it so right here i
have with me this new slam magazine
covers retailing for only twenty dollars
this is a great product it is a old
school shaquille o'neal back when he was
with the lakers and again this you could
hang it display it at your office
that is really hot another thing we're
really excited about is our gold
collection highlighting the hottest
artists this is lil wayne in music and
in sports uh gold collection was just
released last year
i'm just looking for one in our studio
which where is it this is this is harry
potter right
oh the other side
on the other side oh yeah yeah i see it
now okay great and then star wars stuff
still very popular right
so very popular and kendall really
exciting today we actually decided we're
going to send two lucky funko fans and
star wars fans to new york city to see
that big grow goo balloon that floated
down the streets of of new york city for
the macy's thanksgiving day parade baby
follow our original funko channels for
all the details how cool is that a visit
with baby yoda in person
all expenses paid funko is sending two
lucky fans and their plus one to the
macy's thanksgiving day parade where do
they go funko.com
they go to funko.com backslash blog or
check out our social media channels hey
do you have any top gun stuff
oh yes top gun we haven't announced
anything yet but i bet you'll see some
of it in the future i would imagine all
right
jessica thanks so much so much fun stuff
i love your collectibles and uh wish you
the best this week
thank you guys appreciate it all right
rocky over to you
thank you